on va jouer à ce qu'on appelle la
poubelle c'est très simple celui qui
perdra nous d'eux devra à le regarder
dans les yeux
enfin moi dans tes yeux voient dans mes
pieds mais devra dire c'est toi le
patron d'accor avait dit devant tout le
monde et on enverra cette vidéo c'est
aulas tous les états unis d'accord vous
dis bien côté mois refait pas est ce que
vous êtes entraîné hambourg est là pas
du tout sur la télé mon coeur tu peux
être
c'est dingue parce que c'est la première
fois qu'est un mec qui a des pieds qui
sont plus grands que ma personne nous
avions juste une mais deux sont liés
comme ça kenny barron chaussures m'étais
voir que des droïdes bayer faufile dans
les vestiaires aussi alors mais non
c'est bon il a pas de talons allez-y
regarder alors là c'est tellier avec
canon regard des crédits avec talent et
maintenant qu'est descente annonce comme
7 décembre
comme en outre les vols les boules
bleues ou les boulons alors c'est très
simple on va reculer la poubelle à
chaque fois t'as pas truqué motors
non j'ai rien truc et je te jure tu veux
les boules rouges c'est vrai chance que
tu as forcément un truc les bleus lui
qui a choisi c'est très simple on dit là
bas on recule t'inquiète pas tu es prêt
on aura deux chances à chaque fois si on
perd les deux chances c'est terminé on
est éliminé il voit le mal à moi par
exemple j'ai mise à toi ô la pression au
contraire c'est pas les américains moi
si tu peux alors fake je te mets on met
trois boules par truc walton encore y
faire ça car je te mettre un coup de
pression
attention c'est bon pour salle à bompas
au de la saa mois loi oui oui elle après
ça si tu veux des bleus les rouges
adobe a dit débat démarre sur l'a10 deux
morts démarche raide dans un mois
amoureux loin pour muscu je vais mettre
ça pète on fouille dans sa loge une
troisième volet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hélas champions bon outil pour l'équipe
rudi on va un peu double on l'a fait
qu'ils aient tout doute sur le dernier
pour mme allez vas-y vas-y ya battu les
12,1 contre si rien de merkel vous
regarde et de dos en 3d et où d'autres
comme en ce moment au one way point
assez serré la série god put to peer et
topless suivi chercher des balles
j'ai pas battu les américains on
continuera à tomber n'a pas gagné à
dubaï holding ont dit on à deux boules
encore chacun ouais ouais c'est parti
alors toi ton à 3 et redire j'avais vu
comme je suis devenu honnête mauvaise on
vous dit que j'en avais trois chez norma
les faits comme sourit lionel groulx à
lavelanet et foix qu'il enlève sa veste
gestuelle micro
mon frère est un langage non verbal en
guerrière dans votre colle sous la
pression nathan cyril et max tous les
jours ces boules la dernière concerne
les on dit la dernière et après on ad on
a des médias du média à faire les médias
j'aime bien sympa mandat du média à
faire si je la mets déjà façon on a un
petit contentieux tous les deux
ouais il fera pas taire et vos répète a
senti les mecs qu'on peut pas rester
comme ça maintenant il doit pas échouer
ce commerce via jikany nuer les mecs sur
1 m 20 maintenant on attendait alors bas
alors c'était alors bâtiment alors c'est
quoi c'est à la fois que je fais un
autre à lyon pour croire ici j'adore la
fois que je fais j'ai eu des missions à
faire cesser les rues dit tiens on va
commencer l'on allait réside pas de
faire chier l'amerloque tu enfin un rôle
dans l'émission à toi quand on fait on
commence une fois chacun on commence une
voix cheikh sarr a tiré oui c'est ce que
j'ai vu une partie de l'eau merci
mathieu qui a trouvé ton rôle est encore
debout la main aux dames encore une
rouge rouge passion qu'elles sont plus
lourdes les rouges ont été blessés
trop pour moi ça fait un partout
oui en disant que bmp c'est pour info tu
perds le jeune annoncé un partenariat
avec maurice avalanche scénique à gagner
celle-là moi j'aime sa dernière fois en
quatre ans
mais alors la belle
voilà si on perd les deux c'est terminé
on se quitte bons skis de bons amis mais
de mélo cinq matches et bien sûr mathieu
merci jeu pour tout ce que tu fais pour
l'émission allez vas-y brut attendu à
moi et ça joue sur cela peut attendre
c'est finit pas de donner match gagné la
première partie vous êtes détaillera m
tendez les mecs tu comme sur tennis tu
dis on a perdu beaucoup de ses fans
c'est la télé m non une dernière et
c'est fini
[Rires]
la boule qui commence on en a 22 me le
producteur pierre feuille ciseaux pierre
feuille ciseaux là dans la pierre non
non
[Applaudissements]
et en tunisie mais voila voila moi j'ai
touché un situe à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est son métier
[Musique]
j'ai pas de métier vous dit j'aimais
bien paru à la main tu vas voir c'est
très simple il vous dit je voulais dire
devant toute la france ce soir je n'ai
qu'un seul patron
dans le monde je dirais ton nom tous les
jours jusqu'à la fin de l'année dans tpm
paie tous les soirs avant de commencer
l'émission se dirait cette émission je
la fais pour mon maître rudy gobert
alors passer deux heures sur ce sport de
merde